all right that's good to work hey Rome  are you freaking out no yes you are  I said somebody just walked me through  what we're supposed to be doing just  when you didn't think you can  Oh  you're on  I'm gonna get you out of here jump  Oh money to rap you don't know me you're  about to looks like the sins of London  have followed us home remember Owen Shaw  this is big bad brother we're being  hunted  one last ride no when there was to go  now we talk  that is gotta go to work  this is a world that doesn't play by  your rules  and you and your friends are a part of  it now I don't have friends I got family  I can't do it I'm sorry I'll let y'all  down I'm sorry to let you down what  Wow